ok tu peux dire à jean mais j'aime bien
c'est moi
[Rires]
une édition spéciale à aujourd'hui après
il n'aura muriel robin sera de voir aux
alentours de 20 heures 35 et en
allemagne est bien sûr interdit
bonsoir c'est le mec le plus drôle est
une perruque rémois qui me fait flipper
ce qui me fait penser à quelqu'un que je
connais maintenant que tania de parts de
l'acceptable quoi il est formidable dans
le fini il est excellent et tout le
temps avec un et souhaité que ces coûts
d'air aussi mais bouder mois bouder
façon je lis peut dire n'importe quoi et
il me fait rigoler il est trop forte et
trop fort franchement il est trop fort
mais c'est vrai que les deux bouts d'air
à une scène incroyable il un mois seul
qui peut se vanter aussi de joie aladin
elle avait été mariée ou aïd
je crois que ça va être une des
révélations de ce femme aussi je pense
vraiment des 2 et le film est
exceptionnel alors djamel merci d'être
là y'a qu'à vous savez la sauce indiens
savent à trévé nationaux c'est à dire
après tout le monde ça veut dire on a
quelques extraits du film qu'on voudrait
vous montrer dans le film aladin donc
des fils de faire appel au génie qui est
interprété par eric judor et visiblement
j'ai dit à un peu de mal à reprendre son
poste ça c'est une scène qui m'a fait
énormément rire aussi
et éric il a une tête et dans le film
c'est pas ça c'est que en gros ce qui se
passe c'est qu'à la fin du hayon l'avait
libéré oui et donc forcément là
j'aimerais besoin de lui pour tuer le
grand le méchant shazam anne et donc je
vais devoir leur rôle en paix mais ce
qui se passe c'est que et c'est ça que
j'adore danser dans ce film c'est que
c'est des références à notre vie c'est
souvent quand tu reboot ta box et que tu
l'as rallume
ouais elle bugs ouais là c'est pareil tu
relis ton génie et bugs dont qui sort un
peu chez ma mère est très chouette
tu peux dire à jean-michel basset mois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais tu sais moi je le fais vraiment ce
qui s'est passé puisque j'ai vu de
bouddha il est apparemment qui
s'installe chez sa bête a vraiment faim
toiles et autres experts d'al hader plus
c'est vrai que j'ai vu le regard des
chevaux
le père et la reine au caire c'est qu'il
ressemble parce qu'on connaît tous j'ai
bien sûr tu la connais c'est sûr on la
connaît de 5 heures du matin en boîte
genre toi tu fais ch au mieux que ça ça
lui arrive et regarder